it really don't seem like something that
would be a problem yeah dude that's uh
it's like Bart's mom if you even attach
her to electrical wires it's not gonna
power anything nope you can send that
back in time
[Music]
okay since you understand uh Chinese can
you talk can you translate what could be
happening in this clip
just by listening
[Laughter]
foreign
we all need to leave including myself so
we all have to leave right now wow that
that's pretty messed up
so why do you think that even happened
somebody called the cops yeah
is that like an America and they're like
oh it's covered 20. it's in Vancouver
Canada yeah and you have these uh like a
group of senior citizens and they're
saying they're low-income seniors
they're being kicked out of the mall in
the morning for doing Tai Chi oh Jesus
wait that whole area looks Chinese like
the the building yeah is this some
coveted [__] no it's just gathered
it's some private property [__]
isn't that that is sad why aren't they
outside for tai chi I expect them to be
in the public I think it's safer maybe
or maybe it was raining that day or
something it was cold maybe it's cold
yeah but uh that building why is it so
China themed
that's what I don't get I think
Vancouver in general is trying to theme
no but I mean like so I get it if
they're like in the middle of Ross doing
Tai Chi yeah and it's like man I can't
Shop Right but it's in like a Chinatown
area but it looks like they're in a
Chinese temple right it's the commons
area of the mall but also if it was Ross
nobody would complain that's true that's
where they should have done Tai Chi yeah
yeah yeah really yeah but basically uh
they were saying that they're so I guess
there's very few public spaces where
they are allowed to do that so they
would just do it at the mall like this
isn't yeah I don't think that's the
first time they've done it there damn
they can't even do it at the park they
have to do at the mall I guess not maybe
they got like a lot of windy winds and
then the Chinese grandmas get blown away
maybe it's just easier he lost a couple
grandmas wow and so they're they're
doing it at the time where like um where
it says most of the shops aren't even
open yet anyways you know like the early
morning yeah like 7 A.M or something
yeah like when Mall Walkers come through
you know they're they're doing it as
people are opening Shop Smart by the way
since I moved to Vegas you want to walk
outside it's hot as [__] go to the mall
yeah very smart and it is it is safer
like when I used to work at the mall I
would see all kinds of senior activities
happening early like right when I got in
and they would just get everything done
and then as soon as it opens then they
all leave you know or they just like
hang out where'd you work at the mall uh
Cerritos Mall I worked at the cell phone
kiosk that was uh it used to be it was
called mobile Telesis was eventually the
became Verizon yeah sir what was your
pitch as as I go by you know what's
locked him out with my chick all right
so at the time I wasn't allowed to speak
to you unless you speak to me first
really yeah they that's when they
started the Mandate that said that uh
because people stopped wanting to go to
malls because in the early 2000s it
became too Sharky that people would
always go hey what's up you got a phone
man and then it got annoying everyone
hated it so they said the new rule for
mall management is that you have to uh
you can't initiate conversation so if
you said so you can't even even if you
were just silently right in front of my
face I couldn't speak to you really yeah
you have to like say something to me oh
so you got to be like this
and then they're like hi and then you're
like haha I gotcha yeah because you make
them say it's the military call that
Rules of Engagement yeah they call it
don't ask don't tell
but yeah it was uh don't ask them so
like as I would open up I would just see
all these you know the seniors and not
one time that I ever see mall management
tell them to leave or anything they
could do this there that's sad all the
grandmas they all look like what do we
do what did I do exercise yeah they look
all like what they look
cut off guard who's the Scrooge that
called the police on him so uh the
Vancouver seat the actual like City of
Vancouver officials have uh issued an
apology for the for this action
because it's obviously like
the greatest yeah it's kind of it is
egregious and also like if their whole
thing is that they don't feel welcomed
and there's no place for them to go
that's as easy to gather and to me I'm
like if if you're if they're good enough
to you know be your customers then why
don't you isn't that better for your
business anyway yeah to like think make
it what's more welcoming than a [__]
mall now anyway there's nobody there
that's true they're all dying retail is
dying yeah Westfield is [__] yeah it's
a real estate company now oh wow really
yeah well um I wonder if it's the same
for like malls that are predominantly
like Asian like media you know like like
South Coast Plaza has got a ton of Asian
people in it and it's not dying and San
Anita mall not dying yeah they keep
building more like wings yeah it's it's
if anything it's getting bigger better
yeah and bigger and
um
I wonder if they they treat it
differently because it's like an you
know it's not a dead Mall because it's
more like Asian retailers or Asian
customers
I don't know man either a little snobby
about it it sucks seeing the faces of
these disappointed people yeah because
they're not doing they're doing tragic
bro and they're gonna leave in an hour
yeah right yeah they're so old they
don't have the stamina to be there for
like seven hours and they're so old
they're on a schedule too yeah right
yeah they wake up at like four and go to
sleep at like four it says it says that
uh when the senior citizens started to
do their Tai Chi that the mall staff was
like like physically stopping their
movements what they put their hands on
them yeah suck that sucks they put they
would like touch their arms to like stop
them from doing yeah that's just weird
it's weird because that on them for
being Unstoppable yeah they should
[__] do something that means their
Tai Chi is sucky yeah a little bit
because it's like you're gonna let put
someone put hands on you all that
practice you suck fool I see Kung Fu The
Legend Continues they need to train with
Ron honestly yeah Andy's [__] a
singers fight back allegedly too they
were saying that uh some of the staff
that was telling them to stop had said
things like this isn't China this isn't
Hong Kong you can't just gather and work
out here
jeez wow insulted come to Monterey Park
they're friendly yeah they're doing it
at the park like every day right this
isn't China's pretty good yeah this is
in Hong Kong
but I mean what a city to say that in
Vancouver's almost China I know right it
was crazy I feel like it was coming from
Asian employees too yeah probably
they're saying China
get out of here yeah so they're saying
they're not they weren't able to verify
of any culturally insensitive comments
were made but the city does not tolerate
racism of any kind so they've issued an
apology and I think they're trying to
help them find a place where they can do
this that feels comparatively safe like
a Tai Chi Center like a Thai cheese
low it's specific thing they're
low-income seniors so I think that's a
lot to do with why they're at the mall
yeah I feel like all seniors are low
income yeah
yeah like I don't know
no income seniors like they're retired
they ain't making money they're getting
Social Security they're living in like
these 55 plus year old communities that
are like
yeah they're basically on welfare like
yeah unless you're like being taken care
of by your family or you did really
really well in life like I don't know oh
they're all in um Sedona the baller the
baller senior citizens they'll retire
there or they're in a trailer park yeah
but like I don't know any High income
seniors yeah okay I always feel like
people usually just leave Asian grandmas
alone when they're just like exercising
and stuff because they're very
regimented you know they're there every
[__] morning and they just make up
what they're gonna do like they'll be
[__] doing [__] like this yeah
they'll just be doing [__] like this
yeah they don't really do anything they
just be doing like this it's not really
exercise people do it like this yeah you
gotta call the police for that then you
do like this it really doesn't seem like
something that would be a problem yeah
dude that's uh it's like Bart's mom if
you even attach her to electrical wires
it's not gonna power or anything nope
send that [__] back in time
she'll suck up the energy yeah
yeah so I guess they said they do have a
oh it says that Chinatown doesn't have a
community center to host programs for
seniors wow wow that's what must be a
small child that's got to be the only
Chinatown in the world that doesn't have
a place for seniors so they're not going
to let them go in the mall anymore and
do tai chi still I think they're trying
to find a different thing because
technically the mall's private property
so if they just say no none of this [__]
what's the pain in the ass thing though
just a bunch of people doing taichu
before they wake up they're blocking the
Dave and Busters you know where they
would be accepted REI
REI would be down REI should do like a
little Bass Pro Shop oh yeah took a
collab
space
it's old Asian people like fishing right
they like fishing supplies and stuff
yeah yeah what's another good store that
they can go into dude American Store
Robinsons
they don't even exist I think I think
they're all dead now nobody's in
JCPenney yeah nobody's in Sears they
should go to the North Hollywood Sears
that place isn't
they should have someone there to pick
them up real quick when they leave
that's true because North Hollywood
series is [__] it's a [__] War 2 30.
it's a war zone yeah it's like Mogadishu
it's Karachi in there
your bombs going off randomly get it
[Music]
foreign